[Musica]
cos'è la libertà e quando possiamo dirci
veramente liberi questi sono giorgio e
filippo per il mio torico pensato ho
pensato a loro ho pensato cosa
meridonali affinché possano vivere una
vita piena
da qui la riflessione
amerei dare loro strumenti affinché
possano essere liberi e sarei poi
orgoglioso se li utilizzassero per
liberare altri come in un effetto domino
da qui freedom ship se lo cercate non la
trovate una parola cui abbiamo pensato
io e bruno mio socio amico mentre coach
e suffisso ship in inglese sta ad
indicare anche l'abilità l'utilizzo e
quindi quando abbiamo pensato a freedom
se poi abbiamo pensato all'abilità
nell'esercizio della libertà personale
ecco sarei davvero felice se i miei due
nipotini potessero crescere vivere da
persona emozionalmente libere e ora che
abbiamo rotto un po il ghiaccio però
bisogno di togliermi un peso
devo fargli una confessione sono
l'ingegnere ingegnere meccanico per la
precisione che voi direte bene un
ingegnere meccanico che ci viene a
parlare di libertà
se ho fatto ingegneria devo ammettere
che l'ho fatta al meglio possibile
affinché fossi proprio sicuro che non
fosse la mia strada e il più velocemente
possibile per poterla così iniziare a
cercare prima è che non fosse la mia
strada
ve lo posso assicurare se mi date un
automobile tra i davvero fatica a
distinguere il bagagliaio da dal vano
motore
dopo ingegneria cercando di redimermi e
probabilmente peggiorando anche un po le
cose sono entrato in consulenza
strategica e ancora il nesso con la
libertà non è così scontato da lì con il
cervello probabilmente compromesso dalle
due esperienze di studio prima
lavorativa poi ho iniziato a muovere i
primi passi verso quella che si sarebbe
stata poi la mia strada allo studio
della massima prestazione strumenti
strategie e metodologie per ottenere il
massimo risultato possibile nel mondo
dello sport del business della vita in
generale così ecco davanti a voi un
ingegnere evoluto involuto in un mental
coach poi sono in un guaribile
ottimista e quindi scomodando steve jobs
mi piace credere che la creatività nasce
quando la duplice passione per il mondo
umanistico il mondo scientifico si
coniugano in una forte personalità non
so se posso dire di avere una forte
personalità ma intanto iniziato a
mettervi a due ingredienti su tre così
da portarmi un pochino manzi manca però
ancora un tassello
cosa ha a che fare la libertà con il mio
lavoro come vi dicevo mi sono sempre
occupato di performance della massima
prestazione solo negli ultimi anni però
scavando un pochino più a fondo
ho trovato un profondo nesso tra il mio
lavoro e la libertà aiuto alle persone a
liberarsi dalle loro zavorra e così che
possano volare più in alto c'è un detto
nel mondo dell'alpinismo che amo e che
dice piccolo zaino grande alpinista
ecco la cosa che penso è che io aiuti le
persone a svuotare lo zaino da ciò che
non da ciò che non gli serve così da
alleggerirlo da ciò che le rallenta
talvolta fino a fermarlo così che
possano tornare a scalare le vette dei
loro sogni
ok quindi parleremo di libertà
quale libertà di rete direte voi
la libertà di intraprendere strade una
volta sognate ma troppo spaventose per
essere talvolta anche solo pensate
la libertà di scegliere di poter dire di
no senza sentirsi in difetto e di dire
di sé senza voler generare a tutti i
costi un effetto la libertà di fare la
cosa che sai essere giusta senza che
qualcuno lo debba necessariamente sapere
ma solo per essere orgoglioso di te nel
guardarti allo specchio tutte le sere la
libertà di guardare al passato senza
sensi di colpa o vergogna
sapendo che per quanto la vita ti possa
sfidare rimarrai una persona che sogna
la libertà di guardare al futuro senza
ansia e paura ma con la gioia negli
occhi di chi si prepara con cura la
libertà di rendersi vulnerabile perché
si è consapevoli che non siamo
infallibili ma è abbastanza da essere ok
e va bene così perché siamo in cammino
felici di essere qui la libertà di non
dover attaccare per difendersi e di non
doversi difendere a tutti i costi perché
la vita è una festa e non una guerra in
cui combattere mostre la libertà di
scegliere chi esser domani partendo da
chi sei stato fino a oggi di disegnare
il futuro avendo come maestro al passato
ma senza che questo condizione il tuo
stato la libertà di inseguire obiettivi
che puoi tranquillamente mancare perché
non sono lì a giudicare ma solo allenare
la libertà quindi di tornare a sognare e
credere nella bellezza dei propri sogni
e di vivere il sogno come una meta per
cui il viaggio valga addirittura
un'intera vita
beh se ho fatto bene il mio lavoro
adesso dovreste essere vogliosi di
sapere ok quindi come fare a liberarsi e
io dovrei sapere come fare in realtà non
so se esiste davvero una sola strada una
scorciatoia per arrivarci ho trovato un
numero relativamente ristretto di
persone apparentemente emozionalmente
libera e arrivate lì per vi è
profondamente diversa e gli uni dagli
altri e poi e poi chissà se quella sarà
davvero la loro ultima destinazione ho
incontrato poi un numero poco più ampio
di persone in cammino desiderosi
ovviamente di arrivare alla meta ma già
felici per aver
intrapreso il viaggio e poi ho
conosciuto purtroppo un numero molto più
ampio di persone che portano zavorre che
da troppo tempo li appesantiscono ma che
l'abitudine ormai anestetizzato fino a
farlo sembrare quasi normale ecco a loro
va il mio pensiero
penso che la libertà sia un percorso di
cui la bellezza sia il viaggio prima
ancora che la meta che rimanere in
cammino forse sia davvero l'unica cosa
che conta è quindi da viaggiatore per la
libertà in cammino ho piacere di
condividere con voi 5 spunti per
semplificare il viaggio magari
portandoli in palmo di mano
il primo a che fare con la vittoria e la
sconfitta con imparare dal perdere da
ragazzino giocavo a calcio non un grande
talento potrei dirvi che la mia carriera
è stata stroncata da un legamento ma in
realtà ero semplicemente scarso
però sono un tipo competitivo ho sempre
detestato perdere quindi quando da
piccolino accadevano la prendevo
benissimo allora arrivavano i grandi che
mi dicevano paci se vuoi imparare a
vincere devi prima imparare a perdere
mamma questa roba mi davano ai matti non
riuscivo a capire poi da grandi ho
capito il perché mi dava così tanto
fastidio era la preposizione semplice a
che non andava bene imparare a fare
qualcosa significa imparare a replicarla
e non ci trovo nulla di utile
nell'imparare come fare a perdere e
imparare dal che invece significa
accrescere grazia ecco quello mi piace
molto di più
in parole tal perder significa crescere
imparare evolversi prepararsi alla
prossima gara sapendo che se non sarà
una vittoria sarà un'altra tappa di
avvicinamento verso di essa e e poi alla
fine
in realtà non non perdi mai fino a
quando continui a giocare abbiamo
purtroppo paura dell'unica cosa di cui
abbiamo realmente bisogno per arrivare
ad essere liberi di avere successo
sbagliare il secondo spunto poi a che
fare con allenatori e giornalisti lavoro
nello sport ad alto livello da ormai una
ventina d'anni ho imparato che c'è una
profonda differenza tra allenatori e
giornalisti lavorano e vivono nello
stesso ambito guardano la stessa cosa ma
da due prospettive completamente diverse
gli allenatori devono fare delle scelte
i giornalisti e le giudicano
gli allenatori devono vincere i
campionati i giornalisti commentano le
partite nello sport si dice la vittoria
non è importante è l'unica cosa che
conta può essere dipende però dalla
partita che stiamo giocando la partita a
cui penso si chiama vita e credo che
abbiamo l'obbligo di giocarla da dio non
vincerla ma le puoi vincere una partita
giocando male non un intero non un
intero campionato
essere liberi a che fare con come ti
senti con la persona che diventi non
tanto con il cosa possiedi magari
talvolta barattato per quello in cui
credi se vuoi giocare abbastanza lungo
da arrivare a vincere occorre imparare a
stare bene per come ti sei preparato per
come ti sei allenato prima ancora che
per il risultato agisce per la persona
che vuoi diventare prima che per il
successo che vuoi ottenere ecco parla
senza a giudicare ma soprattutto ascolta
senza per questo sentirsi giudicato
perché è vero c'è modo e modo di dire le
cose c'è però anche modo e modo di
ascoltare le cose e nessuno nemmeno te
stesso nessuno al potere riferirci se
non sono gli anni diamo il permesso
il terzo spunto poi a che fare con le
biografie amo le biografie di tuffano
nella vita delle persone puoi vivere le
loro storie quindi qualche mese fa in
pieno lockdown da co vi do un
giornalista durante un'intervista mi fa
una domanda che dice cosa possiamo fare
durante questo difficile periodo che
stiamo vivendo sapere che passerà e per
quando sarà passato scegliere la storia
che vogliamo raccontare questa è stata
la risposta che ho dato tra tra qualche
anno quando terrà i tuoi nipotini sulle
ginocchia e ti chiederanno della tua
vita delle cose che hai fatto qual è la
storia che sceglie oggi di raccontare
domani perché vero le biografie si
scrivono domani ma se vivono oggi il
quarto spunto poi a che fare con con il
chiedere qualche settimana fa mentre
stavo preparando il mio talk mi arriva
un messaggio da un'amica che dice
capaci come stai ti scrivo per dirti che
hai un invito ufficiale a pescara ti
racconto
i miei figli 8 e 10 anni stanno
organizzando il loro mercatino estivo in
spiaggia per guadagnare soldini stanno
facendo braccialetti a mano ai quadri
dipinti da loro scorso anno ricavo in
tre mesi
55 euro in due quest'anno hanno alzato
la qualità dei prodotti trovato un
oggetto da regalare post acquisto per
generare stupore hanno organizzato
meglio l'esposizione studiato una sorta
di campagna pubblicitaria il tutto in
piena autonomia
detto ciò dopo averli ripetutamente
sentiti ragionare chiusi in camera sono
venuti da me ed hanno esposto il loro
progetto obiettivo 300 euro in tutta
l'estate e lavorando di più e meglio è
mamma secondo te se invitiamo pace un
weekend a pescara e gli diamo i nostri
primi 100 euro secondo te e gli bastano
ci aggiungiamo anche vitto alloggio e un
quadro così viene a vendere con noi in
spiaggia ci insegna tutte le tecniche
che conosce compatti secondo noi
vendiamo tutti i braccialetti in un solo
giorno che farò di tutto per essere con
loro quest'estate a pescara loro nel
frattempo di sicuro saranno con noi
dietro le quinte del nostro prossimo
evento credo che se lo siano meritato
magari fino a qualche secondo fa sarebbe
stata anche una sorpresa carina ecco
chiedere a volte svela porte che hanno
serrature che si aprono solo con un po
di coraggio
qual è stata l'ultima volta che hai
chiesto senza avere paura della risposta
ai quali sono i tuoi 100 euro il vitto
alloggio il quadro che saresti disposto
a dare in cambio
chiedi come farebbe un bambino chiedi
tutto ciò che vuoi e dai tutto ciò che
puoi
e se poi mi dicono di no significa
semplicemente che devi imparare a
chiedere meglio il quinto punto ha poi a
che fare con una parte importante della
mia vita che fare con i camerieri
ho iniziato a lavorare a 14 anni come
barista e come cameriere amo questi due
lavori lo portate avanti fino alla fine
dell'università mi hanno
segnato tanto tra le altre cose che
esiste una profonda differenza tra
essere a disposizione ed essere al
servizio ad essere a disposizione di
tutti ma al servizio di nessuno mi hanno
insegnato che se lavori duro puoi
crescere puoi fare strada ho iniziato
facendo caffè cappuccino in un bar poi
addirittura sono diventato barista in
discoteca e cameriera in pizzeria 300
coperti ogni sera ricordo che volava con
le pizze in mano da un tavolo all'altro
cercando di servire il maggior numero di
persone possibile
nel più breve tempo possibile poi
passando dai grand hotel sono arrivato a
lavorare a portofino per me è un posto
speciale
avevamo pochi clienti da seguire per un
numero relativamente ristretto di ore
durante la sera ma dovevamo essere
impeccabili lì tra le altre cose ho
imparato davvero cosa fossero le mance
penso che le mance siano uno dei modi
che clienti hanno per dirti grazie ho
apprezzato davvero molto il lavoro che
hai fatto questa sera per noi il
cameriere è un lavoro che ti aiuta a
conoscere riconoscere le persone dopo un
po con i clienti abituali impari molto
velocemente quelli che sono più generosi
e gentili e quelli un pochino più turati
ritirati
naturalmente se se riesci cerchi di
servire bene tutti ma se puoi dare un
occhio di riguardo a chi lo riservi
ovviamente a quelli più gentili e
generosi ecco la stessa cosa vale per la
vita se hai piacere di cenare in un
posto particolare devi essere disposto a
pagare il prezzo per stare lì
probabilmente il conto sarà salato ma
l'atmosfera è magnifica i piatti
squisiti e poi i tavoli i tavoli sono
molto meno affollati che in pizzeria
le vette delle montagne della libertà
sono sempre molto meno affollati delle
pendici perché nel mezzo c'è una salita
ripida da scalare a cui molto spesso non
siamo stati allenati tutti ne vorrebbero
vedere il panorama ma in pochi sono
disposti a fare la fatica che occorre
per arrivare lì e tra le altre è
un'altra cosa
così come i camerieri quando li tratti
bene se gentile lasciar loro la mancia
dopo un po ti riconoscono e ti trattano
meglio così fa la vita quando sei
gentile con la vita quando lasci la
mancia la vita quando dai senza che ti
venga chiesto nulla in cambio quando
doni senza aspettarsi nulla
ecco dopo un po la vita ti riconosce
come
i camerieri e ti tratta meglio paga il
prezzo per i tuoi sogni e lascia la
mangia la vita alla fine credo che ci
sia bisogno di persone emozionalmente
libere che ispirino altre ad esserlo
credo che ci sia bisogno di leader e più
ancora che di leader di inspire c'è
bisogno sicuro di persone che guidino e
c'è ancora più bisogno di persone che
ispirino ecco cosa dovremmo fare quelle
persone che amiamo con i nostri figli
con i nostri amici con i nostri colleghi
ispirare loro ad essere fare diventare
il meglio di sé così che possano
liberarsi da noi liberare se stesse
liberare altri con il loro esempio
penso che potremmo passare davvero ad
esempi di leadership e già sarebbe
favoloso a esempi di freedom ci stiamo
arrivando su marte stiamo capendo come
fare a vivere su marte è ancora tanto
possiamo fare per imparare a vivere
meglio su questo nostro pianeta da un po
di tempo fa senti una domanda che mi
rimbalzo per in testa per un po fino a
che non trovai una risposta alla mia
risposta a domanda faceva da cosa misuri
il valore di una persona dal numero di
persone a cui ha migliorato la vita
questa è stata la mia risposta come in
un effetto domino
e così come quando con bruno pensando a
freedom ci abbiamo pensato all'abilità
nell'esercizio della libertà personale
penso anche che freedom ship possa
essere un bell'augurio con cui salutarli
l'augurio che mi faccio è che i vostri
cuori si imbarchino su una nave chiamata
vita che poi i piani sulle ali della
libertà
grazie
[Applauso]